red pill
blue pill
dynamic i know we've got a picture of
that so you know a lot of people are
talking about these th these days i
actually did an interview with uh my guy
hafiz from the roommates he was
basically saying that the red pill has
no objective definition and everyone
kind of defines it differently so let's
settle this once and for all what does
it mean
to be red pill what does it mean to be
blue pill okay so uh first and foremost
these are
again abstract terms okay
the red pill as a sort of a terminology
was created or was like we got bounced
around back in the day in the old
seduction communities in the uh
seduction forums and we didn't even
really call it red pill at that time we
said unplugging from the matrix right
because i believed all of these things
about like women i've been playing by
the rules i've been playing by the old
set of you know rule book and i've got
nothing but
i'm i'm single and sexless and i've it
doesn't work for me kind of thing and i
believed all this stuff and then when
men understand their own nature and they
understand women's nature and they
understand intersexual dynamics between
the two of them then they sort of pull
themselves out of this matrix and they
start putting themselves into uh you
know came came out of the gaming
community meaning like pickup artists
and stuff of the early 2000s which
evolved into what we call the manosphere
what we call the the red pill right now
the red pill is a praxeology it is not
an ideology i i got to make that what is
that right now okay
is the study of of like human behavior
with the knowledge that that behavior
has a purpose or an intent to it okay
and there's by the way i'm i'm lifting
that term from like uh from
socioeconomic terms it's not that's not
even like just some red pill thing we
pulled out of our asses here okay so the
red pill to me anyways is from like say
about 2004
is when we started using the term red
pill and red pill was uh i used to think
about women and dating and and and
intersexual dynamics and love and this
and everything in one way and now that
i've learned game now that i've learned
uh intersectional dynamics i think about
things in a different way and so what
happened along the way since that time i
i went back and i looked at my forum
posts from as far back as like 2002 or
2000. i've been doing this a long time
almost 20 about 20 years now and i look
back at that and i go that's the first
instance of me using the term red pill
way back in 2004 and now what's happened
is uh it gets bastardized because
everyone wants to because the popular
term online on the internet people want
to use it for their political ideologies
their their personal ideologies their
religion whatever it is that is i used
to think stupid false stuff and now i
think the right stuff right so the truth
is whatever the red pill is for your pet
ideology and that's why i have to say
that the red pill as far as intersexual
dynamics and the way that it was
originally intended it's a praxeology in
that we're going to go out into the
field we're going to take notes we're
going to we're like you know jane
goodall or dianne fossey on you know the
gorillas in the mist looking at the here
the humans right and so we come back we
create hypothesis from that we we test
those in the field through game or
whatever like red pill and red pill
awareness is the theory game ends up
being the practice of it and each one is
incomplete without the other because one
informs the other that's really what the
red pill was about so when people say
well what's the red pill to you well
it's intersectional dynamics it's not
politics because we kept hearing this
all the time like when trump was was
running for office by the way candace
owens her old twitter handle that used
to be red pill black okay because that
was it was a popular character
politically hijacked
yeah and so then you've got that so
what's an mra men's rights activist
what's a mgtow men going their own way
what's the black pill what's the white
pill what's the purple pill what's this
pill what's your mom
yeah exactly
and so i always come back today
drug-free kids come back come back to
the red pill because what happens is
right now
it get it gets
cast as this ideology all those red pill
guys believe this
it's not a belief set it is a set of not
it's a database it's a knowledge base
it's like the chilton manual
for intersexual dynamics and
understanding women's nature and
understanding men's nature so when
people ask me like what's the red pill i
can't give you an elevator pitch for it
i can't do it in like three minutes i
have because there's so much that's
attached to it it's about sex it's about
politics it's about personal
relationships about families it's about
raising kids it's about i mean you think
of all the things that are attached to
sexual dynamics
in the micro level all the way up to the
macro level that's the red pill all of
that is the red pill and people lock in
on something that like uh conflicts with
their personal convictions and ideology
and they go well the only way i can
explain that to myself is to turn that
into an ideology and therefore i now i
can actually deal with it and i can like
come up with some sort of counter to
that rather than looking at the numbers
and the data and everything else that
comes which sometimes it's depressing
sometimes it's hard to accept that stuff
but you have to remember that once you
get into that and you understand the
numbers and the stats that
it's not as depressing as you think it
is it's just you don't have the
creativity you don't have the you don't
understand how to leverage it to your
best advantage it comes later on but
when people
first become aware of the red pill or
they become aware of intersectional
dynamics of their own and women's it can
be a tough pill to swallow i agree that
was
well so what is the blue pill the blue
pill is your old set of your old order
way of thinking really it's it's uh stay
in what has been uh the the old rule set
the 20th century way of thinking about
like say dating for example that's a
really good uh illustration there
i'm constantly dealing with conflicts of
people who are idealizing say marriage
or dating or whatever and they're their
ideal is cast in a 20th century old
order understanding of what that is
that's blue pill we live in the 21st
century where the rules have changed and
if you don't know the rule set and you
don't you you're gonna you're gonna be
like well i we were playing by this rule
set i thought you know the 20th century
in the blue pill rule set and you guys
are playing
an entirely different game and i can't
win because i don't know anything about
this rule set the the new order way of
thinking about things that's the 21st
century way of doing it so when i when i
listen to say like hafiz or these other
people talking about marriage and
everything all their understanding of
marriage is based on a 20th century
ideal not on a post-marriage 21st
century
[Music]
you